Thirteen real-life years have passed
between the release of "Avatar" and
its sequel, "The Way of Water." For the
characters, the gap was a little longer:
around 14 years. What have
they been up to in that time?
By the end of "Avatar," Jake Sully had
joined the Na'vi cause and transferred
his consciousness to a Na'vi body. He
and his beloved Neytiri have managed
to overcome their differences and
agree to start a life together.
"I see you."
They're still together roughly 14 years later,
and they've had a few kids. There's their oldest
son Neteyam, middle child Lo'ak, and youngest Tuk.
Neteyam and Lo'ak are teenagers who are relatively
close in age. They're grown-up enough that Jake
trusts them to go on missions with him against
the Sky People. Tuk is a bit younger, at about 8
years of age during the main events of the film.
Jake and Neytiri also have
an adopted daughter, Kiri,
played by Sigourney Weaver. Weaver appeared
in the first film as Dr. Grace Augustine,
who died in the conflict between the Na'vi
and the humans. Augustine's avatar body,
which was rendered brain-dead, was pregnant with
Kiri at the time. She's about 14 years old in
"The Way of Water," so her birth most likely
occurred shortly after the events of "Avatar."
"The Way of Water" dedicates a ton
of screentime to these four children,
and it's clear future sequels are
going to develop them even more.
At a "Way of Water" press event, Sam Worthington
revealed that director James Cameron gave him
a script for a project that's become known as
"Avatar 1.5" to help him prepare to play Jake
again. It was Cameron's original plan for a
sequel to "Avatar." Worthington explained,
As we see in "The Way of Water,"
human military forces have only
returned to Pandora within the last year.
So in the meantime, Jake and Neytiri have
kept busy with Pandora business, with their
tribe battling other factions on the planet,
getting themselves ready for
the return of the Sky People.
"What's our plan?"
Maybe one day, we'll actually see
"Avatar 1.5" come to fruition on
the big screen. "Star Wars" constantly
jumps around in its timeline, after all.
​​It may have taken more than a decade
for the military to return to Pandora,
but they came back with some new tricks
up their sleeves. The most prominent of
these is that Colonel Quaritch and some of his
compatriots have returned as avatars. Even though
they were killed in the first "Avatar," their
memories have been uploaded to the new bodies.
They even came up with a catchy name for the
project, which you can see on the avatars' vests:
Project Phoenix. The Phoenix, of course,
is the mythological bird who constantly
dies and returns to life. Theoretically, what's
stopping the military from continuing to upload
memories into new bodies, practically
making their top operatives immortal?
By the time Quaritch and his team arrive on
Pandora, the military already has a full base
set up and operational. They get introduced
to the new way of things this time around,
and it's clear their Na'vi bodies will be
valuable assets in the hostile landscape.
Of course, there's more to be gleaned
between the events of "Avatar" and "The
Way of Water" than what's in the
movies themselves. Fans of comic
books may know there are various "Avatar"
storylines published by Dark Horse Comics,
one of which is the six-issue series "Tsu'tey's
Path." In the first film, Tsu'tey is a Na'vi
warrior who is initially betrothed to Neytiri and
wary of trusting an outsider like Jake. However,
he finds himself mortally wounded
during the events of the film.
Anyone who wanted to believe that Tsu'tey
was more than just someone competing for
Neytiri's braid in "Avatar" should absolutely
check out his comic book series. The events
of the comics all take place during "Avatar,"
but they help fill in the gaps to make Tsu'tey
a more well-rounded character, up until his
untimely demise at the hands of the Sky People.
Set shortly after the events
of "Avatar," the four-issue
Dark Horse Comics series "The Next
Shadow," sees the Na'vi attempt to
pick up the pieces after most of
the human forces leave Pandora.
"The aliens went back to their dying world."
Jake, meanwhile, comes to terms with his
new life. To really drive this point home,
the series starts with Jake going to visit
the grave of his human body. It isn't long
before some of the natural Na'vi are
skeptical of Jake's ability to lead,
and some even plot to kill him by challenging
him to combat with a poison-laced knife.
Jake catches the knife, allowing the poison
to enter his system. While he searches for
an antidote, he begins having visions of his
previous life, including all of the deaths
that occurred due to his inaction. It's more of
a spiritual journey for Jake than anything else,
and he obviously gets the antidote, given
that he appears in "The Way of Water."
If you want to be fully caught up with the
story of "Avatar" before "The Way of Water,"
Dark Horse's "The High Ground," which
is based on a script written by Cameron,
is a must-read. It's set just before the
events of "The Way of Water." Jake, Neytiri,
and their family have lived in relative
peace for years, but Jake has always
been suspicious that the Sky People could
return. And that's precisely what happens.
Humans bring an armada of ships to occupy
Pandora once again. Jake and Neytiri round
up as many Na'vi as possible who are willing
to fight to protect their home. The story helps
fill in the blanks at the beginning of "The Way
of Water." Even though we see the humans return
to Pandora in the movie, it skips past how
their presence impacted the Na'vi. The comic
offers a better sense of the sacrifices the Na'vi
made to protect their home from the colonizers.
With the comic, diehard "Avatar" fans can
get a clearer picture of what transpired
in the sci-fi franchise, so you can
be ready for "The Way of Water" and
anything else James Cameron has up
his sleeve in the planned sequels.